is in full swing the nice weather is
here which means it's time to experiment
with new tastes and textures for spring
tot cocktails joining us now is ralph
floyd you're a global mixologist
absolutely and a very stylish dresser by
the way we could we're twinning right
now my friends where
give us your credentials okay so i'm
really lucky and blessed i've worked
with everyone from gordon ramsay to jose
andres but now i do about 300 properties
all over the world a lot of cruise
industries but i love vegas it's one of
my favorite places to be this is your
town this is my job baby okay where we
start what are we starting all right
let's start off we're going to start off
with a new product here i think it's
really fun it's kind of crazy but um you
can get this one uh at the sky lounge at
the link high roller perfect oh yeah oh
yeah so we're going to show you this is
going to be a nitro cola cocktail nitro
pepsi you have here where do i get nitro
pepsi you can get in cans anywhere right
now but you can only get it on tap
at
so we're going to put a little bourbon
in here go on a little whiskey and now
we're going to create a little magic are
you ready i'm ready for your magic rob
give it some magic too all right we're
going to take a little bit of gold and
the reason i like to use a little gold
here
is it's going to really beautifully
attach
to the nitro bubbles
and start a beautiful gold color look at
the swirl i know and this gold is okay
to drink it is it is it attaches
nitrogen nitrogen is really crisp and
the cool thing about working with
nitrogen and cocktails is you could
shake the drink and it won't go like
normal co2 would that is that's just a i
don't want to drink it i want to stare
at it yeah it's there all day it's
mesmerizing all right let's go on this
and make some more cause everybody's
thirsty everybody's ready it's time to
open up and have a blast here so we've
done that we're going to do a little
less spicy cocktail okay you like little
spices yeah let's get all right
so we have a little black volcanic salt
on the outside here
and to do it we i love the black salt i
love the gold this this texture you had
your drinks it takes it to a next level
well you know i want you to become your
own favorite bartender so that you make
something home and everyone goes wow
yeah i get very animated over there so i
want
all right so i am going to have you pour
in some pineapple juice into here into
our tin go ahead just pour that whole
thing in
nice gonna throw some lime juice in
could you throw two jalapenos in two
uh-huh i can do two
you can do two yes you can make
dressings you make this look so easy
though me and my house
i don't have the gold i don't got the
black socks
so easy all right let's get it some
great tequila two ounces now we're going
to ice this up
and we ice it up when you shake and when
you shake it home you should almost
shake like you're dancing corner to
corner having a lot of fun with it going
dancing around your kitchen exactly
let's see your dance moves i'm a
terrible dancer you're the one that said
it but i make a great drink
when you're having fun at home is
instead of just popping it like this
have some fun with popping it like that
elbow yeah give it an elbow i'm gonna
have you give it an elbow
like a
foreign ship it worked a little
wrestlemania action right there i love
it yeah it's so busy in vegas it's so
beautiful to see
now last but not least we gotta garnish
it we gotta make it all pretty let's
taste this but let's throw a little
jalapeno and pineapple across the top if
you don't mind sir dropping it as i'm
tasting it can you start the next one so
i'll put pineapple and the jalapeno
light on top there please just sits on
top right it sits on top go ahead and
drink this and go ahead and drink the
whole thing be a good show that way
whoa nice does that work that's very
smooth smooth little little heat on the
back get in there with jalapeno that's
good yep all right last drink
drink three we're gonna go tequila
got that in here that lacks all by the
way i taste that it's awesome yeah it's
a superfood of salt that's where do i
get black salted you can order it on
amazon i'd like to tell you something
like really cool but you can order it
there all right so we have this drink
the last bit here you're going to get a
piece of basil i'm going to get a piece
of basil we are not going to muddle mint
or basil we are going to spank it one
two three
that releases the oil and makes a great
cocktail at home put it on in
my i talked to my wife after the show
and she said what did you do on las
vegas now i spanked basil
i've never done that before that's the
final way to get your basil yeah this is
good i think i'm drunk off that drink
all right i'm gonna have you shake for a
bit hold this for a second right there
across that top you're shaking
nice look at that you got a little
ribbon
all right we're gonna put a little
champagne in the bottom
we've got our beautiful cocktail here
let's just take this top off
oh rob you make it look so easy buddy it
is so easy it's fun it's those moments
you share
the moments that we get to share
together that are just weapons so our
basil goes on top of this now just a
little spanx make that basil put it in
you gotta taste this as well oh man okay
here we go
yeah does it work yeah it's delicious
does it work oh my gosh that is
delicious awesome awesome so where can
we find these in las vegas we do want to
get them yes so at the uh sky lounge
skylander scott lounge is the place to
be you know the the link there is just
absolutely amazing and also the reason i
love working with these folks is just
because it's the first time you're
working with nitrogen in a cocktail and
what it does
especially where you can put it on tap
that they do there it's mesmerizing it
is pretty mesmerized thank you so much
you appreciate everybody thank you my
brother
we're gonna drink it we'll send it over
to
you